yeah we're gonna start war shirt because
I was wearing it and I'm too lazy to
change shirt I really wanted to thank
you guys for the love you've shown me on
my last video which was the fans versus
Disney Star Wars in the current
situation didn't know how that video
would land with you guys so far pretty
positive so thank you for that glad I
could speak my mind and have it connect
with you guys so now let's review a
movie I got really excited about since I
saw the first trailer
[Music]
upgrade so upgrade is a movie by Blum
House is pretty much clear sound cliche
first a guy's wife gets killed he gets
paralyzing the attack however here's the
twist so guys like hey I have this chip
called stem it can go into your spine it
can connect the signal from your brain
to the rest of your body you can walk
again little did he know this chip will
talk to him and a voice kind of like
Jarvis from Ironman but only he can hear
it and not Jarvis it's like hey based on
the footage from your wife's murder
please have drones flying everywhere
it's in the future here's one of the
guys who killed her so here's his
address anytime he can say stem take
over and it takes over the worst of the
world Keanu Reeves I know which is
pretty cool what I liked about this
movie first of all the main guy I was
like that guy I'm gonna call Tom Hardy
ish because Tom Hardy ish in this movie
is who you get when you can't cast Tom
Hardy he's very Tom Hardy ish I guess
Tom Hardy couldn't do this movie about
someone with a voice in their head who
kills people because he's off doing a
movie about someone with a voice in his
head who kills people Tom Hardy looking
people love those roles I guess but this
dude in this movie moves past Tom Hardy
as she becomes his own man he's good at
playing the average guy he's good at
like when the wife is killed the movie
itself does a really good job
surprisingly good job anyway at pulling
the emotional heartstrings I just didn't
expect that from this movie not a Blum
House picture and it might be because
it's a Blum House film that it surprised
me if it was any other studio I'd be
like yeah okay work for this particular
movie I was like I didn't expect that
but I thought he was good at playing the
average everyday guy and being emotional
when he had to be him being depressed
and then being a kick-ass war machine
you see this is a twist on the revenge
tale we've seen the basic story of this
film 100 times before oh the wife was
killed I don't have a family anymore
I'm gonna get revenge that was death
wish and death wish was a boring version
of the same old [ __ ] this revitalizes
that concept it's also gonna be really
hard
acting-wise to destroy somebody with
your hands but have your face look like
oh my god I don't wanna do this I was
just really impressed they pulled that
off the movie just came across as a
really effective comic book and I'm
watching it I'm like this is all very
applicable to a comic book
in fact I didn't research it before I'm
filming this it might actually be based
on a comic book I don't know but it has
that this could be a comic book world
kind of like John wick which is a
perfect analogy for this movie it's
Robocop meets John wick with Jarvis from
Iron Man the movie does feel a bit too
long but I don't know what I would cut
anywhere after he gets paralyzed it's a
lot of him in his wheelchair not being
able to do his own thing but you really
need to see that you need to
see that this guy this is his life now
so I don't know what I would cut there
and there is a message in this movie
about giving up control even control of
your body to something anything else is
a very violating thing no matter how
good the intent is even if you're
getting what you think you want anything
that's using your body anything that has
its hand up your ass working you like a
puppet it's an unsettling kind of
concept generally the villains in this
movie I liked they were also very akin
to comic book I like guns for hands I'd
like barrels in the palm of their hands
to like did shoot actually they're kind
of like Iron Man dude for the most part
they worked the main one kind of he's
not what I would expect from the
ringleader in a revenge tale he kind of
looks like kit from Napoleon Dynamite
grew up there's a part of me I was like
it makes him even more weird it would be
less unsettling if you look like a
cliche few just big burly dudes I'm the
big guy but now it looks like he should
be watering his lawn mowing it in the
summertime like hello Chuck wearing his
polo shirt is really weird it [ __ ] up
why it worked for this movie the
disappointing thing about him is I feel
like there's a sub arc with him and his
motivation they didn't really hammer at
home it's kind of wasted that concept
but in the end upgrade was actually a
really good time ally did a good job the
concept is great it's a good
rejuvenation of the revenge tale it was
actually funnier than I thought too I
didn't think the humor stood out to much
higher lie if I had a computer in my
brain that can take control of my body
and I straight-up beat down five guys in
a room I'd get a little snarky - it is
graphic and violent in some of the ways
some of these guys are dispatched if
that bothers you I don't know don't
launch it I thought upgrade was great in
fact it was a great time no alcohol
required you let me see you machine
stalker machines watch this stems take
control Alexa you are wonderful for the
five of you her in your Amazon echo your
mind just got blown here's another one
check this out Alexa play the Macarena
have fun getting that out of your head
okay Jeremy you have control again
there you go the future is now alright
so up great have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and it doesn't
and as always if you like what you seen
here and you wanna see more click right
here to see any more
[Music]